my move University YouTube videos are
offered on a pay what you like basis if
you'd like to pay for the use of the
videos visit my website at move
University comm click on the pay what
you like link at the top of the page and
follow the instructions on that page
thank you and enjoy in this video I just
kind of wanted to draw a side-by-side
comparison for fatty acid synthesis and
beta oxidation and I alluded to this and
talked about this briefly in other
videos and I kind of want to just have
both of them side-by-side that you can
see them so in fatty acid synthesis we
just talked about that in the previous
video so I'm not going to go through and
talk about this you know in detail again
and I'm not gonna go through and talk
about beta oxidation in detail again I
kind of want to just highlight the
differences so um notice just in for
instance like the result of fatty acid
synthesis is we have an acyl ACP
whereas in beta oxidation we start with
an acyl Co a so the difference really in
terms of the structures is just right
here right it's still a thioester
linkage just to a different thing right
and of course we've already mentioned
the differences that that are associated
in terms of you know the oxidation
reduction reactions you know the
reductions in fatty acid synthesis and
the oxidation Xin in oxygen beta
oxidation the dehydration in fatty acid
synthesis versus the hydration in in
beta oxidation and the condensation
reaction versus the cleavage in fatty
acid synthesis oxidation and the beta
oxidation has the cleavage so here one
of the one of the key things is to pay
attention to is that that difference
there and here we have a three cover
molecule joining a two carbon molecule
and this one carbon out here leaves
right that's something that doesn't
doesn't happen at all in beta oxidation
and I think the reason this happens is
that it allows the free energy of this
reaction to be more favorable so if
you're wondering why I think that's part
of the reason for it
so also pay attention to the so instead
of having or excuse me
instead of having
- acetyl co a is here we've got an
acetyl co a or human a co acp and a
malonyl acp versus over here we had two
0s here we had a condensing enzyme
versus a file ways to cleave the file
file linkage however there is a
phytoestrogen that it cuts the file
ester linkage but in terms of the
molecules themselves they're pretty much
identical if you look at the this here
this is a beta keto a beta key to a silk
away this is a beta keto acyl acp that's
the only difference between these two
right the molecules are pretty much all
the same right here this is a beta
hydroxy beta hydroxy a so ACP right so
this one's a co a since a beta hydroxy a
co co a one of the differences here
though is that this one has the beta
carbon is a d has d stereochemistry and
this one has L so they are opposite at
that parallel carbon so that's one thing
that's different about those guys um and
another thing is that the reduction
reactions require reductases whereas the
oxidation reactions in beta oxidation
have dehydrogenases so that's another
difference we already mentioned the
dehydratase versus the hydratase this
you know in oil acp again in oil a CP vs
in oil co a that's really the only
difference so the molecules are very
very similar um I just I mean I really
don't know what else to mention other
than that Oh actually scuse me one more
thing is that both REO 3 duction
reactions in fatty acid synthesis
required in NADPH right whereas in beta
oxidation the two different oxidation
steps one required an F ad and one
required an A plus
let's also something to to note I guess
I really don't know where I'm going with
this video I kind of just wanted to have
a side-by-side comparison to see you
guys can visualize it and you know maybe
find that helpful
anyways I really hope you did find this
video helpful thank you for watching